>> Ukrainian military footage
of a drone strike on a Russian
rocket launcher the bloody war
between Russia and Ukraine is
being fought on the ground and
in the sky, using drones and
unmanned aerial vehicles or
uavs, some of which were never
intended for military use.
This is one of the weapons in
this war, a drone that can fly
far behind the front lines,
carrying a powerful bomb rigged
to hurl deadly pieces of
shrapnel like this.
Ukraine's territorial defense
gave CNN an exclusive look at
what is left of a weaponized
uav, originally manufactured in
China.
Ukraine's state security
service says an agent reported
the launch of the drone from
Russian occupied territory and
troops shot it down at two A.M.
On Saturday.
>> This is remarkable.
The officer is explaining that
his men shot this drone down
using rifles.
Rifles.
So the drone was flying low.
>> The drone was flying low
invisible to the naked eye, he
tells me.
This is where the bomb landed.
The explosive device on the
drone.
>> Troops rig the unexploded 20
kilogram bomb with explosives
and then sprinted for cover.
Officers identified the drone
is a move in five, which the
manufacturer, Mcginn limited,
also confirmed to CNN.
The company is based in Charles
in China, designing air frames
for activities like forest fire
prevention and agriculture.
These drones have been
available for sale in Chinese
online market places like
Alibaba and how about for up to
15 $50,000 prompting some tech
barbers to call it the Alibaba
drones.
>> They can know couldn't use
of their boats and says the
company cease to accept orders
from Russia in Ukraine since
the start of the war, but in
January Russian forces
displayed these images of what
is also a mugen five.
The Russian military claims it
was a Ukrainian uav that it
shot down.
Don't experts Chris Lincoln
Jones call these militarized
uavs dumb bombs.
>> This particular drone we've
been looking at would be much
more effective if it had a
decent camera in it.
The >> Former British army
officer who specialized a drone
warfare says he expected more
from a military superpower like
Russia.